so we can't walk around naked which
means we have to wear clothes and I
think our clothing is an expression to
some extent of who we are I am in the
business of making men feel awesome
about what they wear I think my style
historically has been to overdo it a
little bit I default a little bit
sometimes to too much color I had to
physically restrain myself this morning
to only wear a pink shirt and the crazy
pair of sneakers
finding the right balances that's kind
of a key yeah that didn't work on these
shoes I wasn't able to reel it in
but I told myself as long as I wear a
little bit more formally up top that it
would make for a good balance and open
question whether that was achieved or
not next item is the jeans I'm really
proud of these jeans we just want a
really clean pair that fits well you
know that's dark and to me that's the
staple of of how I think about denim I
was up in Boston and I found this
vintage Rolex I was debating whether I
have to get it I asked what year was
from and he said it's from 1979 which
half this video I was born it was
probably just my own you know retail
retail therapy
confirmation bias but went for it a lot
of how human beings operate is on a
first impression until we get to know
someone we make judgments quickly and I
think the way that you carry yourself is
important I think the way that you dress
is important too